what is this I want to talk about this
this cool mom who's going to jail
because I hate that I hate when a rat
implicates a cool mom everybody knows
that when you were in high school you
were in this weird in-between between
being a child and being an adult you got
to learn how to be an adult and learning
how to be an adult involves drinking
using drugs and having sex
and a lot of times you need like a safe
environment or sometimes an unsafe
environment to do all of those things
that's where the cool mom
it you know becomes a thing
Kathy Griffin used to talk about this
like how Lindsay Lohan's mom Dina Lohan
was like you know one of the moms that
would like you know do coke with the
kids and stuff you know but you know we
had families like that we had a woman
when I grew up who had like uh you know
a big eye one big eye and sold us old
drugs and we we loved her because it's
in someone's got to treat you like an
adult this is my point somebody's got to
treat you like an adult even when you
are undeserving of being treated like an
adult this woman had the gall the
unmitigated Gall to treat children like
adults kids that are raging hormones
that need a place to do drugs and [ __ ]
each other
safely in a wealthy Suburban home this
woman provided he's what a six thousand
square foot house big yeah a huge house
with many different rooms and alcoves
and places to go and she created this
environment where where cool kids or
kids that were in the group were able to
go and get really drunk test their
limits find out how much booze was too
much booze
how are you supposed to learn this
before you go to college and you look
like an idiot you have to learn it in
high school you have to learn how much
booze is too much booze what do you what
what drugs uh agree with your system
what drugs don't you know and what she
did was was create a vibe
truly and and she threatened a few
people because Cool Moms badass [ __ ]
like this woman have to threaten the
weak because the weak are would-be rats
who ruin it for everybody and I mean
let's get into this story a little bit
because as soon as I read it I knew that
a great Injustice had been done and one
of the things that you know about me is
I feel comedy is
um a way to correct all the injustices
of the world that's the way I feel I
don't think it is funny or should be
funny I think it should be about
injustices and just to discuss trans
people from any angle Pro against
confused and you know the Democrats are
new doing they're now doing the bill the
Joe manchin and Kristen Cinema they're
going forward with the bipartisan
infrastructure Bill and they're carving
out money so that Dave Chappelle does
five more specials all about trans
people on and I thought it was a good
compromise I like that um quote here
glad she's gone Los Gatos reels after
Mom arrested for drunken teen sex
parties Shannon O'Connor was known as
the cruel the cool but creepy mom
um read some of this Ben because I read
this I was incensed and enraged and
I don't really
Harvard infrastructure to go and try to
help this woman but if I did I really
would so O'Connor is now facing 39
criminal charges including 12 felony
counts of child endangerment this is
more than bin Laden
this is more than Osama Bin Laden would
have faced by the way all of the people
who've done all of the things
the destroying of people's property the
the burning down of uh small businesses
nobody's like facing anything this woman
is facing 39 criminal charges 12 felony
counts of child endangerment for quote
allegedly plotting teams with alcohol
getting them drunk to the point of
vomiting and encouraging them to have
sex
you know what that used to be called
being cool
what the [ __ ]
it used to be called being cool
she's not [ __ ] the kids she's not
watching them [ __ ] she doesn't have a
Jeffrey Epstein style surveillance
system right right from what I
understand right she's simply creating
the conditions facilitating what may
happen anyway maybe she's lighting a
fire under a few of their asses to get
it going
and she's being charged with
I knew parents back in the day
who would buy us alcohol my grandmother
would buy us a bottle of vodka when
we're in senior year
what is going on here
what are you supposed to do in a high
school party you're supposed to get
drunk
if you're not drinking at a high school
party you're planning a school shooting
what is wrong it's like
the craziest thing I've ever heard this
woman is being treated now she did Chase
down one of the girls and threaten her
in a car but again you have to keep a
tight Circle and this is the thing that
I you there was one kid we used to hang
out with his parents if there was a
fight at the party like his mother would
start beating people and she'd start
like there was a kid on the ground she
was kicking him
they have to defend their Homestead
because when you decide to be the
parents that allow uh
um debauchery and uh that type of thing
to go on when you allow parties when you
allow fun when you make room for fun
when you open the door to a good damn
time people will threaten it Outsiders
come in they get too drunk they
disrespect you they threaten a rat and
you gotta control them physically many a
Time have I seen fights where like the
parenchers get involved because they
have to defend their home
the arrest comes a year after a number
of Los Gatos High School students
started a quote me too Los Gatos move
can you imagine this can you imagine
this by the way
uh high school students started a metoo
Los Gatos movement complaining about
quote rape culture at the school and
staging a rally on campus
at the time school officials said they
could do little but contact local police
about activities off campus which they
said they did in the O'Connor case when
a parent complaint O'Connor 47 was
arrested in Idaho a message left on
herself on Wednesday afternoon was not
returned she and her husband Tech
executive Robert Amaral put their 4.7
million dollar home on sale right to
move to Idaho with O'Connor and her
Three Sons
she's got three kids a 15 year old
and a 13 year old middle schooler and I
think it was a 15 year old and his
friends that she was but which is a
little young it is a little in the
defense of the people maybe overreacting
15's a little young
17 senior year is a little bit more
appropriate but we had some fun junior
year too but and I guess when you start
junior year you are 15. okay so she
would go on Snapchat
and talk to the kids and get them all uh
to come to their house and get boozed up
and [ __ ]
this is what she did and
people have a problem with this yes
I mean
again
doesn't don't people realize
one sophomore girl goes I'm glad she's
gone it makes me feel safer
she purchased alcohol
of the teenagers choosing how cool is
that and encourage them to have sex in
her home in a rented beach house in
Santa Cruz and in a cabin in Lake Tahoe
Jesus Christ you kids don't know how
good you have it don't you know that
this is never gonna happen again
nobody's ever gonna buy you the alcohol
you want and say come [ __ ] Lake Tahoe
on my dime it will never happen again
yes this [ __ ] had some freak [ __ ] going
on yes probably there was some something
wrong I don't know I'm not a doctor but
just looking at this if somebody says
come [ __ ] up my beach house in Santa
Cruz and I'll get you [ __ ] lubed up
with the booze of your choice I'm
telling you right now I know it's
offensive and horrible but wait a few
years you're gonna be dying these same
puritanical monster children are gonna
be in college with their [ __ ] hanging
out of a window trying to get [ __ ] and
they're [ __ ] and dicks I'm not
gendering this but these same kids in a
few years are just going to be they're
gonna be be dying the [ __ ] in a beach
house in Santa Cruz now I do understand
the concern here
uh that the parents I get it because
it's like is she [ __ ] the K it is
weird because why is she so into it
which is weird I get it I understand
that
but I'm talking really more to the kids
now if you're a parent and you're
freaked out about this I totally
understand but to the kids right now
you're kind of being [ __ ] about this
truly
so in one case when a girl was so drunk
she passed in and out of Consciousness
in a bedroom O'Connor brought in a
teenage boy who sexually assaulted her
while the girl cried okay well now this
isn't good
I don't read the whole article
before I do the show
I don't really do the whole thing I do
Cliff Notes
you know what I mean I don't go in and
I'm am I a prosecutor
am I a lawyer
do you think I'm a lawyer
so now this isn't good but this is the
first I'm hearing of this
and the girl says quote why did you
leave me in there with him the girl
later asked O'Connor the complaint said
like why like why did you do that you
knew like what he was going to do with
me first of all too many likes I'm not
saying it deserves sexual assault but
way too many likes O'Connor just laughed
it's unclear whether any of the boys who
are juveniles will face any penalty
some of the teenagers were so drunk they
told authorities that one nearly drowned
in a hot tub and another in a bathtub
but that's funny now the rape is not but
I don't know here's the thing
um that's one boy suffered a concussion
when he fell off the back of O'Connor's
car she'd been driving the boys around
while they were drinking and allowed her
son to drive in the school parking lot
where the other boy was hanging on the
back and lost his grip I mean I mean
here's the deal
the [ __ ] like to have fun
again we are we don't I don't I'm not
this is no good about
the sexual assault thing that is not
good I didn't realize that I thought
this was more of just kind of like get
the kids drunk and we drive around the
school parking lot I mean what is the
woman's really psychotic because she's
doing it in the school
I mean it's wild they moved there
specifically because the sun I met a
girl online playing a video game and
that's why they moved to the school to
encourage him to like hook up with her
and the whole thing so it's very it's
very orchestrated and very weird and
planned
something's wrong we know that
we understand that but is it is it
hacked to just have the same take that
everyone else is going to have which is
like damn this woman to hell I'm trying
now she's accused of 120 000
embezzlement scheme yeah I'm trying to
help you Shannon and you're making it
hard
they make it so hard
you may have noticed this website has
been using the nickname quote cool mom
correct I appropriated that to describe
Shannon O'Connor and by the way even the
the [ __ ] people are saying cool mom
the 47 year old Los Gatos woman accused
of throwing alcohol fueled sex parties
for teenagers and then moved to Idaho
where she was accused of doing the same
there
but we are merely using the vernacular
of the kids as the Mercury News reported
when the story broke O'Connor 47 was
apparently known as the cool Mom since
uh the older son was in Middle School
and had raised eyebrows amongst her
parents for her chumminess with the
son's friends you think it comes out
that she was just [ __ ] the kids it's
very possible yeah it would have come
out already probably though
we all feel that she's a threat to the
community we experienced it I had you
know we had uh uh uh people in Long
Island that were fun that uh parents it
would allow us to drink and use drugs
and they would drink and use drugs with
us but they never uh uh they never
really encouraged sex right
I think the worst thing that happened
once was uh somebody I knew had sex with
a girl and the father at the house
watched it
like my friend noticed he was just
sitting in a corner watching that was
but that was the worst that happened but
nobody knew
beforehand that that was gonna happen
quote we are very grateful that the
judge decided this today and didn't
prolong this and we got to be careful
with how to title this on YouTube
because they're going to give us all
kinds of problems yeah we gotta we we
had dinner with uh some YouTubers the
other night and it's all in the titles
nice people huh did you enjoy the dinner
it was great I had fun I had a lot of
fun I had a lot of fun it was good to
speak to people in Los Angeles it really
is I I like to do these little dinner
things and see where people are at I
want to see where people's heads are at
I think it's funny and here's my thing
with cool mom you know listen as I read
on it's more complex than I had
originally thought I thought she was
just getting people boozed up and saying
you guys can [ __ ] in the house but she's
leading people in the room there's
people getting assaulted that's not good
um she's denied bail now they're
accusing of 120 Grand embezzlement
scheme what does that mean uh so 120 000
in personal charges on company credit
cards belonging to her former employer
that's a lot of booze for the kids I
think I was reading and there's tons of
articles about this I was reading she
like got limos for the kids and there's
there's a lot of stuff charged I'm gonna
tell you this I'm gonna tell you this
many of the kids are going to look back
and say that these were the greatest
times of their lives
not all of them but many of them are
going to look back and say these were
the days
um and it's sad
uh but I remember you know we we didn't
nobody in Long Island uh was a saint who
was uh parenting us letting us have
parties nobody was a saint but here's
what we were able to do of course we
would drink and and vomit and people
would have sex and there would be fights
and whatever you know the the parents
job I would hang out with the parents I
was the one who hung out with the
parents because I didn't want to have
sex with uh the women and I enjoyed my
friends and we would get drunk but I was
always curious about how much money all
the parents had I always thought it was
funny right to I I wanted to know how
much money the parents had so I would
always talk to the parents you know
about all kinds of things the changing
neighborhood
um you know a lot of the things that
were going on because I knew how to get
I knew how to get into their uh circle
of trust that's true you know I would
just sit down in Long Island in Long
Island if you want to get into someone's
circle of trust you just sit down you
have a drink and you stare at them you
go things feel different am I wrong
and they will go on for an hour they'll
be like you're not wrong and here's why
if this wasn't all creepy enough we know
that Arcana and her two sons were found
with at least 10 other teenagers in
their Idaho home on the day that
O'Connor was arrested two weeks ago so
the parties likely continued there with
a different group of teens
so she the cops roll in and she's got 10
kids at the house yes partying
and the whole reason they moved there it
says the son met someone while playing
fortnite online and they believe that
O'Connor moved with her sons to Idaho in
order for her son to pursue a romantic
relationship with this girl and the
mother of the girl said that O'Connor
herself would lavish the girl with gifts
including roses a 200 Tiffany necklace
and food deliveries
is it wrong to want the best for your
children
is it wrong to want the best for your
children